our next speaker is but I see be from
kill me thank you Richard a pleasure to
be here today I'm going to talk about
crowdsourcing for clustering now this
talk kind of there is decision-making in
it I'm not so sure how real time the
decisions here have to be and so when I
was putting this talk together I was
actually originally thinking of doing
another talk then when I saw Leonard
giving the talk before me I thought I
probably should not tread on his toes I
was thinking of talking about tree codes
and their use in control and things like
that and given that he didn't talk about
control at all maybe I should have done
that but on the other hand this is a
talk where I get to show pictures and I
very rarely get to show pictures and so
I'll use that as an opportunity but I
will do one thing now that I I think
about this so I'm going to start off
with a question unrelated to this talk
that maybe I'll answer at the end of the
talk and had i given the other talk that
i'm not giving today i would have built
it around this question and so this is
against something that comes up i think
if you think of trying to do you know
communication control together if you
have noisy channels and you're trying to
control some plant and you have to make
decisions in real time problems of this
type
come up and so let me just ask this
question so let's suppose I have some
signal so s and let's think of it as
being some random variable and what I
know say that it's I don't know zero
mean and maybe it has unit variance okay
and it's a variable I want to convey to
you okay so maybe it's the output of a
plant I'm measuring and I want to convey
it but I get to convey this over some
noisy channel something similar to what
Leonard was talking about and I'll take
a simple case where we have something
called the awgn channel I'm sure almost
all of you have heard about this
basically
the ocean missing the additive white
gaussian noise channel which means what
you measure is say this so this V will
be normal 01 the square root snr here is
to signify that you know this
measurement has SNR given by some value
SNR 10 DB 5 DB to DB whatever so you get
a noisy version of the noise of the
signal and so often what happens is if
you think again in a control scenario
you might have a particular baud rate at
which you're measuring the output of the
plant so maybe every second you get an
opportunity to look at the plant and you
get this signal s but your communication
rate might be different you know in the
simplest case you might communicate s
every time you make a measurement but
often communication can be done at a
higher rate so you might have let's
listen in the next simplest case assume
that we have to channel uses available
so I have this one random variable but I
get to do two transmissions across this
channel say why one with noise V 1 and y
2 with noise v2 which are say
independent and so most people would
think if i get to channel uses than what
i would transmit is i would take the
signal i would transmit it twice and
then i would add up the result the
signal would add up coherently the noise
would add up noncoherent lee and so this
would mean that my snr goes from snr to
twice the snr or we get a 3 DB gain and
this is by and large which is always
done again this is real time there's no
coding going on nothing like that i have
a single random variable to convey i get
to channel uses and i can get to snr
the question I want to ask and I'll let
you think about it and some of you might
know the answer is can we do better and
as I said I could build a whole talk
around this question and I'll give you
the answer may be at the end so that's
the real time part of my talk and I'll
talk about my tongue okay so as i said
i'll talk about crowd sourcing for
clustering i'll talk mostly about
algorithms i've written information
theoretic lower bounds in the title but
i won't really talk about information
theoretic lower bounds not because i
don't have them but because i'm not
proud of them so i won't show them to
you and this is joint work with with my
graduate students current and former in
particular rom you ok so i'm going to
look at clustering and as I'm sure all
you know clustering is the problem it
comes up in you know say pattern
recognition and in essentially what you
have is you have data points and you
want to you know put them into sets that
are kind of similar so you can
understand things better in the
classical setting you know this data was
often given to you as points in some
euclidean space so you know you'd have a
vector and maybe the components were
certain features and you know you wanted
the points that were close together to
be clustered together and there's many
algorithms we heard k-means one of the
questions earlier today and so that's an
example however nowadays you know one
encounters you know different types of
data structures and one that comes up a
lot is not so much where you know you
have a collection of points but rather
what you have is a graph and the nodes
are your data points but they're really
nodes of a graph they're not there's no
euclidean space sitting behind them
there's many examples of this social
networks this is a prime example a lot
of networks that come up in biology such
as gene expression networks are similar
and here when we're talking about
clustering it's not so much trying to
identify nodes that are you know
geometrically close to each other but
rather trying to find ones that are more
connected to
now if you kind of think about this
problem a little bit in contrast with
with you know when you have points where
there's really n data points here a
graph is really described by its edges
and so we can have up to n choose two
edges and so there's really if you think
the size of the data here is is is
quadratic in the number of of notes and
so in many applications it's often too
expensive to measure all possible edges
in the network sometimes you have to do
experiments if these are biological
networks and you're looking at the
interaction of say two particular genes
how they're expressed you may need to do
an experiment you know involving those
two and that is often impossible to do
for all combinations again in a social
network maybe you won't know all the
connections and so on I'll give examples
in a moment and so often what we want to
do is not just cluster based on the
entire graph but a graph where we only
partially observe things where many
perhaps most of the edges are missing
okay so we often need to cluster based
on a very sparse subset of this
underlying graph okay so the task is to
identify clusters in a graph with
possible missing data and to develop
algorithms that have provable guarantees
okay so when I talk about provable
guarantees you know clustering is kind
of a vague notion what do I mean by
cluster so will will describe generative
models for graphs that we'll be looking
at when will try to give results for
those or mathematical results for those
generated models
who knows whether those generative
models correspond to anything in reality
and so I'll also show you a lot of
empirical results okay but let me start
off with the simple idea which is a toy
example so suppose I have a graph like
this and just visually it looks like
this is three clusters okay so this is
the adjacency matrix now you know the
idealization of these clusters would
have been to say well perhaps really you
know it would be nice if what I had or
ideal was not this kind of cluster thing
but actually three disjoint clicks right
so think of this and when you have three
disjoint clicks the adjacency matrix has
this you know if you label the nodes in
the right way of course has these blocks
of all ones these rank 1 blocks so i'm
assuming every node is connected to
itself so i have ones on the diagonal
and so a graph that say consists of
three clusters kind of looks like this
except you know if you look at this
thing here it's not a perfect click so
there's zeros and you know there's
connections between the clusters so it's
not all zero down here you have
occasional ones it looks something like
you know the adjacency matrix looks
something like the adjacency matrix of a
set of disjoint clicks yes sure how was
the
noisy toy bull generated from the ideal
I'll talk much more about that in a
moment this is just motive this is just
cartoons I'll get that end I'm just
trying to motivate the idea the idea
that we'll be using is to take the
adjacency matrix of the graph if we
observe all of it if we don't then we'll
have to do something else and try to
decompose it into a low rank component
and a sparse one the low rank component
will represent the clusters by
essentially placing a click on top of
all of them connecting everything within
a cluster and the leftover which is you
know the edges that we're missing from
clicks or the edges that were connected
between clusters will end up in this
sparse component so that's the idea ok
and so if I have to write an algorithm
this is what I would write you know
given the adjacency matrix a decompose
it into lower rhine component plus a
sparse component where I guess both of
these are 0 1 well L is a 0 1 matrix s
is a 0 plus 1 minus 1 matrix and
minimize say this objective the rank
because i want the rank of l to be low
some regularizer times the support of s
because i want the number of you know
nonzero entries in s to be small ok of
course no one can solve this integer
program the only thing I want to say
about this is the rank of L of course
determines the number of clusters and so
what to do nowadays you know people want
to convex if I everything so we'll do
that so the rank will convex if I with
the nuclear norm the sum of the singular
values of the matrix L in this case and
the sparsity we will relax to the l1
norm the sum of the absolute values of
the entries of the matrix s and again
Owl previously is between 0 and 1 excuse
me it was previously either 0 and 1 and
I'll relax that to lie in the interval 0
ok so this is very intuitive it's a
relaxation all it requires is knowledge
of the adjacency matrix
and so you can run this and see what
happens and so incidentally this idea is
not new it perhaps first appeared in
work by Candace and others Candace was
not interested in clustering he was
interested in robust PCA and so
suggested a similar decomposition in the
PhD thesis work of Venkat chandrasekaran
where he was looking at trying to find
latent variable in graphical models he
also required a similar decomposition in
the context of clustering this was first
used I guess by jalali and sanghavi and
aims in lavasa seeeeee and we've done
some work which I'll talk about in a
moment okay so to your question yes
model in question Jeff what's the
motivation behind the having the low
rank peace explicit I mean in some sense
the the fact that you're paying for the
connections between the clusters is just
sort of it's from an optimization point
of view also going to sort of determine
the correct number of clusters oh so
it's even meaning one would think that
in most applications event ending that
that's also a second order kind of
phenomenon rather than a first order for
them I know you're waiting it by the
land of so you would your your
suggestion is to just include this not
care about life okay so it turns out and
I'll shown the analysis there is a
particular value of lambda which at
least for the generative models that we
will look at performs the best and and
and the rank of Al kind of helps us to
identify the number of clusters as we'll
see in a moment but I haven't looked at
the case where where you drop el all
together so again many of you are
probably familiar with this model so
this is the generative model on which
I'm going to base the analysis on again
who knows if this generates anything in
reality it's called the stochastic block
model it's kind of a generalization of
airdore any random graphs where you take
two nodes and you just connect them with
you know Heidi with some fixed
probability P here what you do is you
have your end nodes they're already
separated into say K disjoint sets which
will be the clusters and so the way i
generate a an instance of a graph from a
particular stochastic block model is for
each cluster there's an associated
probability P I which is the probability
that nodes within the cluster are
connected ok so there's capital K of
these because there's k such clusters
and then there's a second probability Q
which is the probability that I you know
connect one cluster to the next and you
can have more elaborate models where
these r qi JS but let me know do them
and the only assumption really is that
you need more connections within
clusters
outside and so you want all of these P
is to be bigger than Q okay so this is
for example what the realization of such
a graph would look like now in addition
I'm going to add one more twist or maybe
two more I'm only going to partially
observe this graph and I'm going to do
that randomly too so in other words each
edge in this stochastic block model will
be independently observed with some
probability are okay and finally you
know I'm also going to leave some wiggle
room for outliers so this is you know I
have K clusters and I is the number of
nodes and cluster I so these are the
nodes that are in clusters that's the
total number of nodes and i'll have some
outliers the theory will allow for those
i also so when I say what I observe is I
look at a pair of nodes and I observe
whether there is an edge or not okay so
that's what I know what I don't know is
for other pets au pairs that i do not
observe I don't know whether there's an
edge or not so is this eve
what kind of the cluster is a relatively
small ball get tell of that depends on
what r is it depends on what r is and
again what the cluster sizes are but I
will come to that I mean the cluster
sizes will will play a big role I mean
in the analysis that I will do in
particular the smallest clusters will be
important but most of the analysis that
I will do will be for constant P Q R
although some of it can be extended so
let me just show you the performance of
this naive convex program okay so this
is an example it's the network with 600
nodes no outliers three clusters of
equal size q is taken to be point 1
lambda was taken to be this value which
turns out to be order wise the optimal
value to take I'll talk about it a
little bit later and so what I'm showing
you here is the success rate success
here is a very strong notion of success
it means that we identify L perfectly in
other words L breaks up perfectly into
these sub matrices of block size one and
I'm looking at the probability of
success as i increase p so q is fixed
and here as you can see you know things
are not working once p picks up above
point six then with high probability you
succeed the only difference with the
program i showed and maybe had that
there is my constraint of course because
i'm not seeing all of the matrix i only
have this equality over the observed
parts of it and so this observed to your
question can have zeros and ones now if
you think about this program it's pretty
clear that you know if if P min if the
smallest of these P is is below one half
there's no chance it can succeed because
if i have a cluster for which less than
half the edges are present from the
clique it's always beneficial for me to
declare it to zero and push everything
here in TAS okay and so you're kind of
seeing that's all this is already not a
very good program I mean depending I
mean there are situations where perhaps
team in is bigger than
and a half and I'll talk about that when
i do the empirical stuff but certainly
for things like social networks this is
not the case right so if you think of
social networks a of university students
in the US maybe they're clustered based
on universities and berkeley could be a
cluster i'm pretty sure pi/4 Berkeley's
not one half every Berkeley student
doesn't know half of all the other
Berkeley students but i'll come back to
how to go around okay so let me show you
the result that we can prove for the
stochastic block model for the simple
algorithm i just described an important
quantity that comes up is what we call
the effective density or the minimum
effective density which is this quantity
here you minimize over all the clusters
the product of our which is the
probability of observing an edge ni is
the size of the cluster 2 pi minus 1
which really is saying how close TI is
to one-half which was this critical
ratio that we had and again it turns out
so there's a certain value for lambda
which is this if demon is above this you
succeed if it's below it you fail with
high probability i won't give you the
formulas they're complicated instead
I'll kind of show you the consequence of
rewriting those formulas so you get
success so this is a sufficient
condition for success this inequality
has to hold so this is kind of my
minimum effective density so this has to
be bigger than what's over here now
these terms have interpretations this is
kind of like a noise term coming from
how connected the different clusters are
to one another it involves the queue and
this is kind of the variance of the
Bernoulli Q random variable this also
has an interpretation that I won't go
into but but the bottom line is that if
you take q and r and p is is constant
this stuff over here behaves like Rutan
okay and so really what it's saying
again if R and P and everything is
constant that the minimum cluster size
has to be bigger than root n for for
these things to succeed we also have a
failure condition which is this and it's
not absolutely ty
but at worse I think there's a factor of
four between these but the root n is
really what's coming up I won't go
through the proof not that that was a
proof anyway in one slide but not even
into the proof it I mean it's just we
look at the KKT conditions and sweat and
work hard okay so here is a simulation
result just to show you things so here
I'm plotting so black means I guess
failure white means success here i have
the observation probability are and here
i have the minimum cluster size p is 62
point 85 q 2 point 1 and 2 600 and as
you see as the minimum cluster size gets
small it becomes harder to for this
thing to work and these are the upper
and lower bounds that's the actual if
you think performance so there clearly
is some kind of a phase transition okay
so that's fine the problem is I said
with with the simple program was that if
p is less than one-half it'll take those
not very well connected clusters and
preferably push them all into ass and so
the simplest idea to get around that is
to insist that this part you know have a
sum that's at least something right so
if you have an idea of what the total
cluster sizes or a lower bound on it and
one can often observe this from the data
itself you can insist on this okay and
so this works when provided you know all
you really need is for Pima now to be
bigger than Q but other than that it's
the exact same program we had earlier if
i take the simulations we had for 600
nodes each of size 200 so three clusters
q 2.1 and i run the success rate versus
p so the probability of connection
within a cluster this one works for much
smaller p so it picks up as soon as you
hit points
so it's it's certainly an improvement
over the the other program okay and
again I won't go through it there's a
similar theorem for this one as well
these expressions look a little
different the root n is still there the
big difference is here what we have is
previously p i was compared to one half
now it's compared to q it's as long as
you're above q there's some wiggle room
for Anna okay this is a more complicated
program and so we don't have you know a
sufficient condition for failure here
let me mention a few things about
related work so the convex algun the
first one I described the one you know
which doesn't penalize you know or put a
constraint on how many non zeros l
should have was first introduced by
sanghavi and co-workers and their
analysis had a result like this so our
analysis basically cleaned up this log
in I know some people don't care about
logins and they say in practice it
doesn't matter and that's probably true
but I think logins matter to people who
know how hard it is to remove them so it
matters to me now it does because
there's other results on spectral
clustering which I won't talk about one
connection I do want to make is to the
planted click problem so the planted
click problem is this problem where you
have an air door any random graph those
things or you know connected randomly
and you go and you plan to click inside
so you take some subset of the nodes and
you connect them all together and the
question is can you in a few
computationally efficient way find this
click and so there's considers
conjectures saying you can't do better
than root n if you want computational
efficiency and so despondent montanari
have a 2014 paper where they work really
hard with the specific convex program
specifically for the planted click and
they show n min has to be bigger than
point 6 root dang if you take our result
which is much more general because we
have clusters and so on and outliers
which is plug in the parameters for the
planted click we get to root n which is
not too shabby a given that you know we
weren't looking at this planted click
problem even just the show so our
analysis is not too bad I think
and it's getting it extends to much more
general things and just one so here's a
simulation result for that and so let me
that's kind of the theory part of all
that if that was theory let's now do the
fun part okay so why were we interested
in this and why is the word
crowdsourcing in the title of this talk
okay so what we're interested was the
following problem trying to label data
okay so suppose you have any want to
generate label data say for some
supervised learning task okay so let's
suppose we have some database of images
of say dog breeds so this is a norfolk
terrier this is a toy poodle this is a
movie ado I don't know what if lund or
something now if you have an expert and
you show them this picture you know
it'll be able to be able or she'll be
able to tell you what breed this dog is
but most if you don't have that expert
you ask me this is a dog and so is there
a way that we can somehow crowd use
crowdsourcing to generate these these
labels and so the approach we took was
that even though most people won't be
able to look at a picture of a dog and
identify the breed you can give them
simple tasks for example comparisons
they can do pairwise comparisons are
these the same breed or not probably not
and so on right and so if you think of
the way to do this and so we looked at
you we took say Stanford's dog database
we took 473 images of dogs of these
three different breeds and so you can
think of a you know a graph where you
know every dog in the same breed is
connected to all the other say poodles
or whatever so there's these disjoint
clicks but what you observe is not this
but rather noisy versions of the edges
so you can ask random people you can
show them a pair of images and ask them
you know whether they think they're
connected or not whether the same breed
and so since you'll get a noisy response
you'll get some indication of whether
they're the same
but you know not exactly and furthermore
you know even with a database with 473
dogs I don't know 473 choose to
apparently is 111,000 you can't really
query 111,000 pairs of images and so in
the experiments that we did on Amazon
Mechanical Turk we had workers come in
see 30 pairs of randomly chosen images
and answered the question we had earlier
whether these are the same breed or not
and we observed about fifteen percent of
the edges which is sixteen thousand
pairs of images and so the question is
can we identify that there were actually
three different breeds and so this kind
of fits the model that we have so it's
something like the stochastic block
model because if I show you images of
things that are the same breed hopefully
the chances that you'll realize that the
same breed is more than the chance of
making a mistake and so your P is say
bigger thank you and so we did this and
it turned out that the workers had about
twenty four percent error so a quarter
of the time they would make a mistake if
they were shown to the question of
whether these are from the same breeder
okay so these are the empirical example
so 473 images three clusters these are
the cluster sizes we saw fifteen percent
of the entire graph the probability of
making an error if two things were not
the same breed was about twenty percent
the probability of correctly labeling or
not labeling but identifying images that
are the same breed are these three
values so poodles were hard to tell I
guess than the other two okay and so you
can take these numbers and plug them
into our theorem assuming that there's a
stochastic block model behind all of
this and you quickly realize that you
know the theorem says that shouldn't
work
in fact it turns out that for the
theorem to to show that it works we need
to go out three times as many images to
see nonetheless we ran the algorithm
even though we were guaranteed of
failure and so this is what we got here
and so the reason why this is fairly so
you can kind of see the three clusters
but of course there's errors more so in
the poodles than the other ones but
already it does something of a job and
so let me numerically show you what it
does so had you taken the pairwise
comparisons and fed them to k-means so
the columns of the adjacency matrix you
would have made 193 errors out of I
don't know 470 images if you run the
convex program and then take its output
which is this and give that to K means
you go down to 34 errors if you do
spectral clustering on its own spectral
clustering works well in this case only
gives 19 errors because if you look at
the spectrum of the adjacency matrix you
see the three dominant eigen values but
if you run the improved program to
recover owl and then apply spectral
clustering to it you only get 13 errors
and that's because it really cleans up
the eigen distribution so lambda is is a
1 over root n just done oneself yeah
that's just dumb monsters and so you're
down to 13 errors which is like below
three percent errors which is nice
for this max's we rarely crowd sourced
and apart from three percent errors were
able to label or at least identify the
clusters and then if you show an expert
just one image they'll say this is a
poodle this is a bull via to flaunt or
whatever okay so the next question I
want to ask is what can we do beyond
pairwise comparisons you see because
often what we're given is we're
constrained by given budget so when
we're doing this Amazon Mechanical Turk
experiments I told romneya that you have
500 bucks to do this case yet she had to
figure out you know what to charge the
workers and what the query and how many
queries and so it's not clear if you
have a fixed budget whether their edge
queries are the best thing to do so I
want to investigate triple queries or
we're all called triangle comparisons
where I'm going to show people three
images and I want to look at the
clustering performance in this case and
I also what will be important because
i'm giving a budget to her the cost of
the query will be important three images
is a more complicated query and so it
should cost more so let's look at
triangle queries for a second so in
triangle queries I show three images and
they need to identify which of these
belong to the same breed and so there's
really only five possible answers
they're either you know these are all
the same braids or these two are these
two are these two are and none of them
are you have three forbidden responses
these are forbidden so clear one
because of this you know because of the
associativity of being the same breed
right if these are poodles and these are
portals that had to be put so there's
really five responses
skip always okay so for this we in
addition to dogs we looked at birds and
so this is a caltech database now and so
there was an albatross I don't know what
turns are but the print is such a bird
Arctic version and the least version get
a cardinal green Jay and we threw in
some other birds as outliers so these
are hard to tell right the only
difference I can see is really the beet
color and I don't know if that's
consistent but there were any way 340
images these five clusters and outliers
50 or so outliers and so the edge query
is just you know are these the same
breed the triangle query you see three
images and your ass are these all the
same species is only one and two the
same species only one and three only two
and three or none this is the five
possible ends ok and so let's kind of
think whether this triangle stuff will
help or not now whenever you do a quango
triangle query okay so for example if I
duty independent edge disjoint triangle
queries so these are triangles they
don't have any edges between them you're
really saying 3t edges you're querying
3t edges but they're dependent edges
right they're not independent ones and
you can take these edges and put them in
this adjacency matrix partially fill it
and you can run the convex program and
see what happens and so if you recall
this was the condition for success you
know if I had a certain model with our
as the number is the probability of
observing an edge in Te & QE the
probability of success I mean of there
being an edge within a cluster and
between clusters if you have triangle
queries you'll get a similar result the
only differences are has to be replaced
by RT so the fraction of edges I see
when I do chronic triangle queries I
have to replace these with PT and QT so
this is the probability of there being
an edge when I do triangle queries it
could be different from PE the only
difference really that shows up here is
this factor of three down here
and that's really because when you do
triangle queries they're not independent
edges that you see so you pay a price
and that's the price so one minus one
third is kind of you know bigger than
this so this lower bound goes up that's
the pro that's the price you pay for not
seeing independent queries okay so I
have that written down and so the bottom
line is that if with triangle queries
you have the same number of observations
of edges and if the probability of
observing a correct edge and making a
mistake on the edge doesn't change
triangle queries are worse because we're
not seeing independent ones but that's
why do triangle queries the reason is
these assumptions are not true okay so
when you do triangle queries it often
happens that P of T gets better than PE
and cutie gets less than QE and the
reason is when you show users three
images there's some self correction in
right so if people were looking at to me
images and we're kind of doubtful
whether you know these are the same
breed or not if they see a third it
might be able to resolve that ambiguity
and we'll see this and so in other words
we might expect that PT is bigger than
PE and QT is bigger than QE and then the
second assumption that we made was that
we were seeing the same number of edges
but that would only make sense if the
cost of a triangle query was three times
the cost of making an edge query right
because then I'd see the same number of
edges but that's not clear whether the
cost is really three times I'll get to
the cinema
ok
and so to answer these questions I'm
going to look at some generative models
for triangle queries how much time do I
have about two minutes to me so I'm not
going through the generative models
anyway they're generative models that
you can come up with which are
generalizations of the stochastic block
model which we call triangle block model
and conditional block model and which I
won't go into but it turns out that if
you believe those models and they make
physical sense to me I didn't go through
them you can you can quantitatively show
that this happens the fact that out of
the eight possibilities three are not
allowed allows for self correction so
that's a game so you get more reliable
edges when you do triangle queries and
then finally what about the cost ok so
again think of Amazon Mechanical Turk
suppose when i was doing edge queries I
was you know giving a dollar for every
user who you know responded to an edge
query now if I give them a triangle
query how much should I pay them right
so somebody might say well you know
we're seeing three edges so you know
don't be stingy pay them three bucks
someone else might say well they're
really only looking at three images as
opposed to two so I'm going to be stingy
and I'm only going to give them one and
a half dollars someone else might come
in and say well that's not really it you
know when you were doing edge queries
there were two possibilities now there's
five so there's really log 5 bits of
information there so this is what I
should give them or 2.3 so already I
have the full gamut between 1.5 and 3
and someone else might say you know this
is not true either because it's you know
this log 52 was assuming those five
responses were equally likely and if the
cluster sizes are different and all
that's not the case and so you really
should look at the entropy of observing
you know particular triangles over you
know edges and then someone else might
say well no no
because this is assuming my workers
perfectly identify what's going on
they're going to make errors and so what
I should really look at is how much
information their response is giving me
about the true triangle if you think
about it the real cost is really how
time it takes for the worker to do a
triangle query over how the time of
longer take something this way if it
takes them 10 times more to do this you
have to take play them 10 times huh so
we've done this thing we've done
experiments and there's one of these
five that almost always matches this
anyone have a hint which one it just
didn't change from experiment to
experiment that's the thing so in all
our experiments one of these always
match this which one one the answer is
two and the interesting thing is so a
shish coil from Stanford had visited
Celtic a couple months ago and he does
this kind of stuff for rankings and
elections and so on so he asks people to
rank items he sometimes gives them for
items sometimes eight items and why
asking this question he immediately said
the answers to the and and so apparently
the reason is that when people see
they're making these decisions the bulk
of the time is understanding the data
here they have to absorb three images in
the edge case they have to absorb to for
example what I she said is if you're
ranking for objects it's true there's
four factorial possible answers if
you're ranking eight there's eight
factor which is a whole lot more but it
takes people twice as long to rank eight
objects supposed to focus really once
you've absorbed these eight objects the
ranking time is negligible and so on
everything we've done this is about 1.5
it's even a little less so to summarize
this part when you look at triangle
queries as opposed to edge queries the
pros are the edges are more reliable
because there's self correction because
the cost of a triangle query is less
than three times the cost of an edge you
actually see more edges for the same
cost in fact you see twice as many
normalized to the costs the cons are of
course the edges are not independent but
in everything we've seen both simulation
wise and empirical evidence suggests
that the pros really outweigh the cons
and so let me show you some empirical
evidence I'll try to wrap up quickly so
we did this both for dogs and birds so
when we had 300 workers looking at edges
we see about 7.7 percent of the edges
the error rate is twenty-five percent
when you normalize say to the cost you
get to see twice as many edges and the
probability actually have an edge error
you know in both cases here drops from
twenty-five percent to twenty percent
which is what we were suggesting that
the edges are more reliable for the
birds it's something similar it goes
from fourteen percent error to about
eleven percent so then we did the
clustering I'm short on time it works
better is the bottom line when you
whether it was the birds or the dogs I'm
shortened i have minus five minutes so i
could go on add noise IAM because I did
triangles and you can do what rupal
which I won't do but I want to say that
there is another angle to look at this
which I think which gets to the
information theoretic stuff which I'm
not proud of but I'll just set the stage
there's a way to look at this okay so if
you look at crowdsourcing what do we
have we have items that we want that are
drawn from some finite alphabet say dog
breeds which you want to label there's a
taskmaster who assigns queries and or
constructs queries and assigns them to
the crowd there's a crowd with imperfect
skills which makes errors and responding
to these queries and there's a crowd
source or who tries to analyze the data
if your information theorists this maps
perfectly to what you use to the items
are like a source the taskmaster who
makes the queries is like an encoder the
crowd is like a noisy channel the crowd
source was like a decoder and so the
question of interest is if I have a
fixed budget and I want a certain
fidelity how many queries should I ask
and you can put it into this framework
which we've done and I'm not proud about
the results because the assumptions are
kind of weak I won't go into it but
there is a connection to joint source
channel I think I'll stop here and if
you want to Lancer the question but
otherwise i can take questions or i can
answer my office let's see what's the
answer so the answer is the Archimedean
spiral
the most sense what is the Archimedean
spiral why is the answer the Archimedean
spiral so what is the Archimedean spiral
right it has this equation I guess
radius is equal to angle something like
this and so it turns out and i'll let
you do this exercise so if i'm given
this the source s what i'm going to do
is I'm going to set theta to be equal to
square root of SNR times s and then I'm
going to look at this hour comedian you
know whatever and i'm going to choose
whatever theta i got and then i'm going
to look at the x1 and x2 that i get from
here and that's going to be my first
transmission that's going to be my
second transmission and my claim is it
if you transmit like this snr goes not
to to snr with s and r square
you know I'll leave it for the talk in
the fall or whatever we're doing this
relevance and exercise you guys can do
but I was talking to a neuroscientist at
Intel whose name I forget now berkeley
neuro scientist and when i told him this
he said the brain does this i don't know
if the brain does this if there's an
Archimedean spiral in the brain anyway
so this kind of shows being a little bit
clever is better than just transmitting
toys totally related to the analog or
error correcting codes stuff you're
doing my face feeling curves thank you
so you got 1 plus epsilon of a top
the plaster main problem we have the
case passes the case passes Scott this
kind of similar with suppose also to
solve this problem when you run for
Buster to have K clusters such living no
minimum knock edge between the clusters
okay related you know any connection
because solutions seem similar existing
the toy example well so that's assuming
you know the entire graph so again so I
haven't thought about that problem i'm
sure there's probably a connection i'm
not sure this would be the relaxation I
would do if that's what I would my
objective would have been so I don't
really have much to say beyond that but
I haven't really I mean sounds like
there's a connection simple and
everything and this seems to be very
easy but I don't so want to say this is
easy to sew again NP hard to me so you
know as an idiot you know talking about
stuff NP hard to me it seems you know
when we say NPR what's of interest is to
kind of get away from NP heart you know
and so I think the moral of this story
is that if the cluster sizes are you no
larger than Rutan and you know if these
conditions hold then it's not an np-hard
problem yes right so but but in general
yes I mean if I ask in general for this
problem trying to identify clusters it's
probably as hard as heart can be
whenever the connection between the
problems it's not clear their case of us
discussing this it lists time he replied
yes okay right thank you